the testimonies of detransitioners I
think it's some pretty ghastly stuff and
most but not all those people are
Abigail Sharia writes about this
irreversible damage these are basically
young gay kids told that they're born in
the wrong body and then they they need
to transition I heard Katie Herzog say
in an event once that she's she's gay
and she said that there are no her I
think she termed it Femme friends said
that there are no Butch lesbians anymore
they've all transitioned wow okay
actually there's a Hannah Barnes who's
written a book called time to think
about it was happening in Britain and
she shows it's it's something like of
the female trans it's over 80 percent a
gay and of and I think if the male trans
is over 90 it's highly and then very
high autism autism and that's also it's
changed over time I think in the last 15
years it was a majority a male
phenomenon and now it's become a
majority female phenomenon